[Musique]
bravo franck tu es le premier homme à
avoir escaladé cette montagne dix mois
nous avons réussi à le faire tous
ensemble
[Musique]
mon frère de mon homme de confiance et
meilleur ami mon fils sera désormais le
responsable
de la fronde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je t'aime à la folie fera la folie à la
folie
[Musique]
aller à la maison tu es supporter grave
tu as vu ce que tu fais tu avais bien
dit de tenir loin de ce bourgeois mais
il ya est il simple employé c'est la
femme de ma vie père j'étais un enfant
de france
tout ce qui peut
[Musique]
je prouverai le moyen de me discréditer
qu'est ce qui t'a vu france ne m'a rien
fait les crises
[Musique]